cinq choses à savoir dans ce budget
2016-2017 de carlos leitao le troisième
budget de carlos leitao
premièrement contrôle des dépenses ça se
poursuit rigueur austérité contrôle des
dépenses on appelle ça comme on veut et
ça nous donne donc un surplus pour une
deuxième année de suite de deux
milliards de dollars
deuxièmement investissements en
éducation après des compressions au
cours des deux dernières années on
augmente le budget en éducation de 3% en
investissant notamment de façon précise
dans le soutien direct aux élèves et aux
étudiants notamment l'école maternelle
l'école primaire et beaucoup
d'investissements prévus dans les
infrastructures scolaires qui en ont
bien besoin à bien des endroits mais 3%
c'est quand même pas une augmentation
notable historiquement on s'attend à
plus en éducation en santé également
seulement 2,4 pour cent on est vraiment
sous les coûts de fonctionnement du
secteur de la santé
troisièmement les garderies et le
tonique vous bien là c'est
incompréhensible parce que non seulement
il ya une contribution additionnelle
maintenant à payer dans votre
déclaration de revenus si vous envoyez
des enfants dans des garderies de places
subventionnées mais en plus lorsqu'on
apprend dans ce budget c'est qu'on va
réduire de 50% la contribution
additionnelle que vous avez à payer sur
votre deuxième enfant qui est en place
de garderies subventionnées et si
rétroactif à 2015 tout ça pour vous
aider un peu à vivre ce choc tarifaire
en quelque sorte
si bien sûr vous subissez on baisse la
contribution santé de 25 à 50 dollars
pour à peu près tous les contribuables
du québec à partir de 2016 et
graduellement la contribution santé va
disparaître en 2018 et la cinquième
chose à savoir c'est le programme
rénovert vous voulez rénover votre
maison vous pouvez avoir droit à un
crédit d'impôt qui pourrait vous donner
jusqu'à 10000 dollars c'étaient les cinq
principales mesures à connaître de ce
budget l'état